hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today is brian
fogle brian is a filmmaker he won an
oscar
for his documentary icarus which if you
have not seen it you must he was a guest
on the podcast a couple years ago
brian is back with a new film it's
called the dissident which is about
the murder of journalist jamal khashoggi
it's extraordinary this conversation is
utterly compelling i think you guys are
going to really dig it
so hit that subscribe button and please
enjoy my conversation
with filmmaker brian fogle
[Music]
my name is genius i am addressing you as
a victim
a title forced on me after the brutal
murder of my jamal
jamal khashoggi prominent saudi
journalist and washington post columnist
has gone missing after visiting his
country's consulate in istanbul
he was last seen entering saudi arabia's
consulate seeking paperwork to marry his
fiancee
his fiancee saw him go in at 1pm and was
still
waiting for him at 1am
saudi arabia now suddenly he's admitting
that his shogi
did die inside that building
[Applause]
the government treated me as if i shot
the king we knew that
they would try to sweep the whole thing
under the rock
is it true that turkish intelligence
obtained audio recordings
khashoggi's murder
i know why jamal was killed it's because
of me
[Music]
we saved some particularly damning piece
of the puzzle like
saudi body double
jamal felt the whole country was against
him but this is not the truth
i said the best solution is create our
own army
the king firmly denies any knowledge of
it it could have been
rogue killers
i just received this be careful move
from city to another one
and there's a team is going to kill you
soon it's anonymous
he has to be killed in a way that will
send message to everyone else
because if you kill jamal with his
fathers who
else you cannot you can kill everyone
we're in german once you start working
with us you're not just a journalist
you're a dissident
what do you know about the beast
good to be back in the same room with
you man and a lot has happened
in the last couple years in your life
it's been a crazy
trajectory for you yeah it's been um
it's been an interesting uh a few years
that's
that's for sure what was it like when
you
won the oscar and you're up on that
stage i mean that has to be one of the
most surreal experiences you can imagine
um it was uh it was march of uh
2018. um and
it was surreal and what was interesting
is leading
leading up to that the the months up to
it um
uh icarus released on netflix in august
of 2017.
and um the academy awards was august
september october november december
january
you know eight months later uh seven
months later
and um netflix had
you know had put a lot of energy behind
essentially this award campaign
and i'd never went through anything like
this before
and so it was seven
months of every day of my life you're
waking up and
here's your schedule for the day right
here's your press here's where you're
going here's your screenings here's
where you're go you know and it was
and it was it was intense and so
you know the lead-up into that was
months and months and months and months
and months of this you know kind of
campaign um and so i
i came into the to the you know
but from the time we get nominated to
actually
going to the academy awards and there
i'm there
sitting there i mean it felt like there
was a
an elephant on on me
like i wasn't at that point having fun
because it
it just it was amazing and at the same
time the pressure
because it was just there was so
much feeling for me at stake
and um and netflix and my partners and
everything had put
so much into it and so we were all like
there kind of like on
pins and needles and luckily they
called uh the award for best documentary
i think it was like the third or fourth
award yeah early in the night which was
really really good because
like you know you're sitting there and
you know
they called icarus and i just remember
like
at that moment i i essentially had left
my body i mean it was just
you know you you're walking up on the
stage there and you know there's
you know this person that person
everybody in the entertainment
that front row just looking up at you
you've ever admired and you're sitting
there going like
wow i'm i'm on stage at the academy
awards with a
oscar in my hand they handed me that
oscar and it's
i don't know how many pounds it's it's
like 12 13 pounds or 10
i mean it's it's heavy i was like whoa
and uh that was completely surreal
and an actor uh uh
won the statue you know you're led into
this
labyrinth underneath the kodak theater
and you come out of the labyrinth about
an hour later because they walk you
through all these like stations of
photos
right and then a booth like what was it
like to win the oscar and all these
you know kind of surreal things and you
emerge about
an hour later and as i kind of emerge
out of the cavern about an hour later uh
right where the backstage is um
is uh i can't remember if it's is it
joel or ethan cohen who's married to
francis mcdormand
i think it's joel joel so uh
joel joel is there and francis won
the academy award that night for best
actress
and um and he goes to me
enjoy this and he goes yeah he's like
he's like because you know he's like you
never you know
he's like the odds are this is never
going to happen again
and he goes like he also goes he's like
you know
and he tells me this this crazy funny
story
um about sylvester stallone that i won't
repeat
and i just went i'm like this is so
surreal i just won an academy award
there's um i really should
remember if it's joel or ethan cohen um
talking to me like they're my favorite
filmmakers of all time
you know and uh it was it was quite a
night
it's pretty cool and my parents were
there too oh that's nice yeah
the campaigning that goes into the oscar
season
is bananas there's so much at stake
for these companies it is bananas
and what's interesting is in covid now
you know uh it's so radically different
right because
you can't press the flash and go to all
these lunches and all that kind of stuff
and all these screenings where
you know with icarus you i had i don't
even know
you know 30 40 screenings were small
screenings and you're meeting people
and and it was wonderful because i i got
to meet
so many people so many people that i
looked up to or
filmmakers or documentarians or you name
it
um and so covet has really really
changed that but
it was it's really intense because
you're
you're also there's like a playbook
you've got your talking points
and you've got your you know like the
do's and the don'ts and what you're
gonna say
and what you shouldn't say and and how
to answer
a question and everything was so like
um it was it was intense yeah it was
intense
and uh and the press i was doing you
know you then kind of like
you know you'd go do an interview and
then after the interview it was like
okay that was really good but
you know maybe change the next time you
answer the question
do this you know well
you know thinking back to when you did
the podcast you i mean you're definitely
lighter in your shoes today than you
were on that day there was a
you know we had just met so we didn't
know each other really but there was a
there was a
a little bit more of a seriousness and
maybe a sense that you were shouldering
that kind of heavy responsibility at the
time
yeah i i just i was uh it was
interesting i i remember going through
that so well because
and i was enjoying it and at the same
time i actually was
i was so stressed out yeah because each
one of these events you do these events
then it was like
okay was that okay and then i'd like
replay it in my mind and go like did
i did i answer a question the right way
or did i say something that was
wrong the publisher is gonna call you
and chew you out for
listen if you're going on podcasts
though and you're talking for a couple
hours
you know it's um i i mean
the the entire lead
up to um the uh
uh the oscars and and just that whole
season i mean it was so intense and we
had
um we had been nominated for a bafta
um and so i'd been at the baftas like
two weeks before that and and we didn't
win
and so you come out of the bathtus and
you're feeling you know like completely
defeated right but
you've got the oscar nomination and and
everybody at the time was going well
don't don't worry about that or
the you know the uh you still got
uh the oscars and um
but it was uh i i
i mean it was it was an incredible
experience but i can't
tell you that i was like having fun yeah
during
yeah yeah yeah during that period i i
felt
um and part of it really had to do with
um
what icarus was about
and that here as this whole awards
season is going and
um gregory rachankov the whistleblower
to this day is living in hiding in
protective custody
is isolated
and so it was what was weighing on me
also was that okay here
i am having these experiences and
um being celebrated
and the guy who
without him without him possible yeah
this wouldn't have been possible without
his evidence without that story
none of this would be happening is
basically living in isolation
in an unjust undisclosed location under
security
under the threat of his life and
you know uh here i am on this completely
different trajectory now
and uh and that and that really
weighed on me still weighs on me
yeah i mean my first question i mean
we're here to talk about the dissident
your new your new film but we can't get
into that without
hearing a little bit about how gregory
is doing like are you in communication
with him
like what's the latest i know he put
this book out recently
he uh put his book out
which is uh his
memoir of you know his his life
and actually i can say this now because
by the time you hear this it'll be known
it just won the william hill sports book
of the year which is a very
prestigious prize in the uk uh so he
just won the basically british sports
book of the year
award for the for uh for the book um
and yet the book still doesn't have a
u.s publisher which is
bizarre yeah i noticed that he
self-published it
no it was published by penguin random
house in the uk
and then we couldn't get a us deal for
it
um i was involved just as
no financial stake nothing just trying
to to help facilitate
um but the book's pretty amazing
and uh um and so that
you know came out a couple months ago um
but
i'm not able to um
you know communicate directly with him i
don't i don't have his
phone number i don't know where he lives
um
i don't want to know where he lives um
but
we've been able to stay in touch through
his lawyers
um and uh you know he's doing
okay but uh he hasn't seen his family
since uh since he escaped
uh russia which was in
november of
uh 2015. uh
he went into protective custody
in july of 2016.
uh so we're you know four
years in now four and a half years in
of essentially this guy living in
isolation
uh in protection and what's interesting
is that
the story has continued to evolve he
um when icarus released in august 2017
russia was still going to the olympics
five months later basically because of
what that
film's impact had been on the world at
that point and
and the global distribution that that
netflix has
uh the olympics the ioc essentially had
to do something so even though
at that point the story had been in the
press and the media it
you know it's very different okay you
see something on cnn or read something
in the new york times versus
now you're emotionally connecting to a
character and you're
seeing this in a film and you're
realizing the extent of this fraud and
kind of how bad it really was um
the ioc you know decides to
ban russia from the pyeongchang olympic
games in 2018
and in the decision of the ban even
though the ban was largely ceremonial
because russia
was then able to still compete but not
under their own flag and the athletes
were competing as
olympic athletes from russia um they
cited icarus and their reasoned
uh decision wow and
so that was you know uh
the olympics i think were february 2018.
mm-hmm
and then at the time there was the
still is wada the world anti-doping
agency had put together this road map
which was okay here's the three things
that russia needs to do
to get reinstated into world sport
and one of them was that they were
supposed to provide
the lims data which is the laboratory
management system
data of everything they had been up to
over the past like you know
decade kind of thing like okay we know
you cheated
but you guys got to come clean and you
need to provide this data
because they had believed that you know
that
what was in this database um
was a ton of other doping violations
and frauds that the urine swapping
and the opening the bottles and all the
other kind of stuff
and rachenkov gregory had said yeah this
is you know
there are tons and tons of cases in here
that you know
that i entered into the system is
negative that were actually
positive right and here's what we did
so that was the first thing they had to
turn turnover
the second thing for russia's
reinstatement
was that they were going to accept the
richard mclaren report
which was after we brought the story
public to the new york times in
may of 2016 richard mclaren
uh the investigator who was brought in
by the world anti-doping agency to
investigate
rachenkov's allegations authors this
report over the next year
and the report you know basically you
know goes
down a rabbit hole of of insanity of
how big this fraud was and it was all
backed up through scientific data and
researchers and
forensic evidence etc and that russia
had to accept
the mclaren report as fact right
and the third thing um
was that there was going to be like a
massive reform to the anti-doping system
and that there'd be all this oversight
and all this stuff right
so they had set this as the three things
that russia had to do to get back in
and here we are basically two years
later it's now
actually at like the beginning of this
year right
and russia still hadn't accepted the
mclaren report
still hadn't returned over the limbs
data but wata
reinstates them into competition
basically just going back on the
on their own you know word that this had
to happen
the point of this story is that they
finally
turn over this limbs data and i don't
want to mess up a date but this is
sometime around
a year ago they finally turned over the
limbs data and
in turning over the database russia
go had went in before they turned it
over to wada
had manipulated the entire database
but wada already had the real database
that rochenkov had turned over to them
of what it was supposed to be right
right
and now the one that russia's turns over
is basically
been completely manipulated to erase all
these positives to erase rachenkov's
evidence
but not only that they had made notes
into the database
pretending to be gregory writing these
notes
to basically blame the entire scandal
again on rachenkov
that this was all a big conspiracy that
rachenkov had acted
as a sole practitioner kgb fsb had
nothing to do with this the state wasn't
involved
and water goes
what is this guys like are you kidding
me
uh-huh and so they basically re-ban
russia
for another four years and this is where
it stands right now today
that's the current state russia is still
suspended from international competition
um had the olympics happened
this last summer in 2020 the
recommendation was
wata was going to be banned from the or
russia was going to be banned from the
summer olympic games
we don't know if that was going to
happen because they were fighting that
in the court of arbitration foreign that
was unresolved
and the ioc had made the decision so you
know where this stands right now you
know
here we are you know essentially four
years on but
two years on from uh the winter games is
russia's continued to deny their
re-band band again as of right now
they're not going to
the summer games if they were to happen
in 2021.
emerald chankov is still not only is he
persona non grata
if you pull all the russian media i mean
this guy
is essentially the arch enemy of arch
enemies
right of in the overall history of the
russian
federation i mean and as long as putin's
in power that will
remain to be the case i mean we've heard
reports from
you know through his attorneys from cia
intelligence
um is that he is you know either number
one or number two on russia's kill list
um about a year ago if you remember
there were nine russian agents
that were kicked out of the country um
that actually trump administration had
discovered these nine basically
secret agents that were working in the
country and they kicked him out they
were supposed to be
i'm gonna botch this story but
apparently they were russian diplomats
and whatever
but then the state department determined
they were spies right so they were
actually
working on behalf of the fsb to come and
and sort of root out ronchenko here in
the states
apparently three of those agents of
these nine that were expelled from the
united states
were here hunting rachenkov um
and there's been reports on bellingcat
which is this
investigative circle of journalists
that even when he was supposed to appear
they
russia thought that he was going to
appear at these hearings
in luzon switzerland um which of course
you know he appeared via like skype or
zoom but they thought that he was going
to be there in person
and there were agents that were in luzon
essentially
waiting for him um there's all sorts of
you know evidence that's been uncovered
in the last few years of
you know they're they're hunting this
guy that's so dark
and um you know you look at uh nalvani
the guy was poisoned in germany whenever
that was five
six months ago um with a nova chalk and
and scurple you know uh which was in
march of 2018
uh in the uk the you know that poisoned
him and his daughter
lithanenko um and then all these other
mysterious
murders and some that have you know been
looked at as hangings and
and suicides and this that and the other
um
it is clear that uh you know russia
doesn't forget right
wow so um how has this impacted you
personally like are you on the receiving
end of
some of these threats veiled or
otherwise
gratefully i've i've never received uh a
threat um
and i've never received an email threat
or a text message threat or social media
threat
um and you know the way that i've always
looked at it
myself is that um
you know why would you shoot the
messenger
and i think you know russia and you you
even hear
putin when they asked him
uh about the the the scroll poisonings
and you can go look at interviews and
they go well did you do this
and he goes no i i didn't do this but
treason is the highest crime and it
should be punished
so yeah you know basically i didn't do
this but yeah
you know if somebody did do this this
was warranted because
treason is the highest crime and i think
you know and i
i can't speak for how um you know
russia but if you look at like even the
poisoning of alexander lithinanko in
um or scurple right it was these were
acts of treason
and gregory is viewed as a traitor
um a defector um you know and
i would imagine that even gary kasparov
is on that list
you know uh as as a defector and
uh and a guy who was the pride of russia
who has now
you know come very very public in the
past
yeah several years um you know against
putin um but uh hopefully i'm
you know i'm okay and i uh uh needless
to say i'm not planning any trips
uh to moscow anytime soon yeah
and and now probably not this not uh
saudi arabia
yeah definitely not saudi arabia
it's a perfect segue into the new film
because that's essentially
you know an overlapping narrative with
what you explore
in the in in the murder of khashoggi
this idea of you know
power unchecked where whether it's putin
or mbs they kind of want you to know
it's them
without saying it's them because they
want to put the message out that they
mean business
but perhaps there's also an under
appreciation for
the kind of global response and reaction
to these events
where there's a growing intolerance for
this kind of thing
like i suspect that mbs didn't
anticipate the level of
outrage that he kind of invited
upon himself as a result of all of this
well
i don't think he expected uh
that there was going to be a
bug a listening device in the saudi
consulate in istanbul
right that was going to blow the land
beyond a shadow of a doubt i mean just
flat out what had happened in
um that that consulate and
um so i don't i don't think you know the
the
the khashoggi murder um
was just horrifying but i don't
i don't think that mbs um
when you go into the details of the case
it was so stupidly planned
and it was so brazen and outrageous
but obviously they
they couldn't have imagined that there
was a listening device
in the consulate in the room that they
decided to murder him in
and that's a whole story about that
peace
foreign
[Music]
right i mean that was a big question and
before we get too deep into this we
should probably just
synopsize the film a little bit for
people that aren't familiar
but what wasn't completely clear
is how that recording transpired like
who
who set that bug how did that transcript
you know get compiled like who who hit
record on what device
and for what purpose that basically
records the entire process
of of murdering this journalist well
what did
what had happened um as i learned in
in making the dissident is
there was they had decided
the saudis that they wanted to rendition
jamal khashoggi back to the kingdom
uh he was uh
you know he was writing in the
washington post
you know not defending trump and
the saudi regime trump was a huge ally
so he was speaking out against u.s saudi
relations
and trump um he was working with a saudi
dissident
in canada basically fighting
saudi arabia's control of twitter which
is all part of the film
and he had come out you know as
speaking publicly that he didn't agree
with a lot of parts of
muhammad bin salman's vision 2030 which
is
his concept of how to reform the kingdom
but everything that jamal was writing
about if you go back and read his
washington post writings
or even read books that he had published
in arabic
is he was a moderate you couldn't even
consider him a liberal right
i mean this is a reformist from inside
the system
yeah this was a uh um a
a moderate reformist who loved his
country
who had no problem with the monarchy
he just believed because here was a guy
who had been
educated in the united states he had
been coming to the u.s
and to the uk his whole life you know
most of the time working for the saudi
royal family as as somebody who was
either
uh you know not a diplomat but a you
know a liaison
he speak he spoke fluent english or as a
journalist
for the kingdom writing about you know
what was going on
um and so this was a guy who really uh
was entrenched in that system in the
family
and so his defection from the kingdom
was
an insider who you know
who really knew what was going on there
knew these people
um but he was portrayed all of a sudden
in western media's
muslim brotherhood as a terrorist
sympathizer as a guy who knew
bin laden and al qaeda and all this
stuff and this was not true
he was a moderate who loved his country
and what he was writing about
wasn't like you know down
with saudi arabia nbs must be overthrown
you know the royalty has no place the
monarchy must
you know uh must abdicate the throne
none of that was going on
this was a guy who was going i love my
country we have a young prince
who i believe is starting to lead the
country down the wrong path
he's talking about reforms he's talking
about okay women can be able to drive
and there isn't going to be this
the the guardian system where women have
to check in with
any man in the household who's 18 years
or older to get permission to leave the
house and
all these things that that mohammed bin
salman was
talking about changing in the kingdom
and at the same time he's
completely crushing
opinions he's crushing anybody who
has anything critiquing of him
you know just anybody who dares speaks
anything other than
this guy is essentially the chosen
perfect
you know right monarch of all time
and so what jamal was really writing
about was was hey
um we can do better we can be better
and you can be a monarch and also be
kind
you can be a monarch and be
compassionate you can be
you know a king or a prince and inspire
your people
rather than repress them and that was
the the core of what he was doing
and that dissent led to a place where
you know had he stayed in saudi arabia
he surely would have been jailed
and in leaving he became hunted
and um and ultimately the decision was
you know
uh to to murder him right so
historically the relationship between
the monarchy and the press and saudi
arabia is kind of
hey geographic right like your job is to
basically speak kindly of what's
happening in the government for the most
part
exactly he was able to still
advocate for some level of reform
within that construct and still covet
favor with those in power he kind of
knew where that line was and how
much he could push without transgressing
it
but my sense is that over time beginning
with
arab spring and kind of everything that
happened after that he started to get a
little bit more
active pushing the buttons a little bit
more a little bit more
seeing where that line was and at one
point he crosses it perhaps even
unbeknownst to him and there's this
edict that comes down from the monarchy
where they kind of disavow themselves of
him right and then he realizes like
basically he's [ __ ] and he like
catches a flight out of
out of the kingdom like that night
without telling anyone thinking
he could pop he could go back at some
point but
we all know he never did he you know
and and you see in in the film uh we
show some
old clips of him and you see um
you know him speaking in english and
appearing on
you know on western media uh speaking in
english
and so he here is this guy who had spent
his whole life
you know back and forth between the west
and saudi arabia
but you know he's uh you know he's in
the kingdom
and he starts essentially
speaking out not not
in any sort of like aggressive way but
basically tweeting
or writing hey you know oh
i don't agree with this or maybe this
can be different
and um and this guy was was listened to
he had 1.75 million followers on twitter
which you know is a big number
especially in saudi arabia
and so he was very respected so unlike
you know let's say a you know a young
up-and-comer or this that the other
this was now a a very respected
journalist you know
coming out with his thoughts or opinions
and somebody who knew the inside
workings
and so muhammad bin salman
had kind of put together this whole um
you know i guess army as you'd call it
of people
uh to basically see to it that that you
know there were
no free speech or freedom of opinion in
the kingdom
and assad al khattani who was
uh one of the royal advisers uh
basically apparently comes up with this
plan of how
they are going to you know see to it uh
you know that that there is no free
speech in the kingdom
and saud reaches out to jamal and tells
them
don't write don't tweet don't talk
you're to remain silent
and um and basically if you don't
we're gonna we're gonna come and arrest
you right um
and there's threats being made and
jamal essentially makes a decision
that he has to leave he can't remain
silent
and and and this decision
we get into in the film but you know he
was
he was married he had children
his kids were living in the united
states at the time
i didn't know um and uh
two of the kids were in the u.s one of
the kids was in was in saudi
uh was my understanding and um
you know and he was happily married
and he makes this decision that
he has to leave um and he has to leave
but i think for two reasons as
as i understand it and his friends
uh who you know who i got to know in the
making of the film
tell me is that you know the idea that
that he would
sit there and be a lame duck and be
silent and
and that his whole life was as a writer
was as a journalist was i said you know
that now he was his voice was silenced
was enough that it was so compelling
that that
that he felt that it was better to
to leave the country than to stay with
his family and be silenced
and of course i think you know his
family probably
you know was not thrilled with that
decision
and uh you know after he leaves he comes
to washington
he gets a job
being a global opinions writer for the
washington post
and there's a story
and i certainly can't validate the truth
of it because of you know for for
reasons
but apparently um the
the saudis come to um to his family to
his wife
and tell her um that
she has to uh uh
you know to divorce jamal
because only a husband can grant a
divorce from his wife in the kingdom
women
women are not allowed to divorce a man
has to grant
a woman the right to divorce and
apparently they
they brought her in um and
you know interrogated her and whatever
and said you're going to call your
husband
and tell him you know that you're
that that he has to grant you a divorce
and
uh and he did and um
and he did because you know for her own
good
so that you know so that so that they
would leave the family alone
um and uh and so he
now was in washington and
you know he was uh essentially isolated
yeah
um and that began
the rebuilding of his life it began
essentially his uh ultimately finding of
heteja jengas
know the girl that woman
[Music]
that he decided that he was going to
remarry
and that led to him going into the
consulate in istanbul
where he is murdered because he had went
there to seek marriage papers to prove
that he was no longer married so that he
can marry hatija
it's devastating the idea that he would
leave his
entire family behind knowing he would
never see them again
well i think that he he believed
um that well the kids
were in virginia and washington two two
of them
at the time they're now back in saudi
arabia and i think the whole
they decided in the aftermath of his
murders that basically they had two
choices
as i best understand it choice one was
fight for justice for their father and
you know the family would
basically never be able to travel right
um
be arrested have their you know be
ruined
right because you know how are you going
to take on
this kingdom and you have so many
cousins
and relatives and aunts and uncles and i
mean you know
so so it was like okay either we're
going to go fight for our father's death
or we're going to sexually accept to pay
out
there's stories that the payout was in
the tens of millions of dollars
and remain silent and move on with our
lives
and the family decided to go that route
um because i can understand that
because it wasn't just about the kids
it was our aunts our uncles our sisters
our brothers our cousins that you know
um either we're going to you know
uh uh whatever war
we rage or fight
in trying to fight for justice for our
father is putting every member of our
family
in danger um so i think ultimately the
decision was made is okay we'll
go back to saudi we'll you know we'll
shut up
we'll move past this and we'll take the
money
in the structure of the film it's very
interesting the way you kind of set this
up you have these two
protagonists that are essentially on a
collision course with each other you've
got khashoggi
and all the events that led ultimately
to his murder
but in parallel with that there's this
other guy omar
who's left the kingdom and is living uh
in uh in montreal and ultimately these
two cross
paths on this kind of trajectory that
that khashoggi is on
from reformist journalists to
becoming you know essentially a
full-blown dissident
so talk a little bit about how you
structured the film because it really
does
i mean i haven't even said this yet but
it's like the the film is extraordinary
you did an unbelievable job it's so
compelling and it plays very much
like a narrative thriller like on some
level it's more like a born movie than a
documentary like the score
all of the sound design like every
element of it
is keeping you on pins and needles the
whole time and there's like a gestalt
like a tempo to the movie that really is
is very hyper engaging and unusual for a
documentary
well thank you um that's
certainly how we and you know myself and
my
creative partners wanted the film
to feel sound look
structured is
[Music]
much like icarus but in this on a
heightened level
i looked at this story and said okay
it's a thriller it's all true
but this is a thriller the
the murder the story of
why he's murdered how he's murdered
um all the forces at play the characters
this is um like a bourne film
and and so there was a very intentional
construction cinematically
and how we structured the film pace the
film put the film together
and used these cinematic techniques
that you would see in an enemy of a
state
or in those born films
or you know you name the kind of the spy
thriller movie that were intentionally
employed in the construction of this
film
while remaining true to being a
documentary i mean everything in the
film
we shot everything in the film is a fact
everything in the film is researched and
archived and backed by evidence
but structurally
my feeling as as a filmmaker and my you
know collaborators
is i think if you can engage an audience
you know
visually you know through sound music
motion graphics effects all these kind
of devices
that when you're watching like a big
thriller get you on the edge of your
seat going
what's going to happen next and if you
can do that
and especially in the case of this story
then hopefully the
the come away from from watching the
dissident
isn't just that you're on the edge of
your seat and you're
having that kind of cinematic
thriller-esque experience
but that it also leads to a call to
action
because you're emotionally impacted
because you didn't just watch
a piece of news you went on a journey
and that journey becomes very emotional
hopefully
in watching the film and that leads um
what my intention would be and uh
is that there's a call to action behind
it that you come out of the film
and you fall in love with adisha jenga
is his fiancee
you care about omar abdulaziz and that
his brothers are still
jailed and saudi with no with no charges
and his friends are jailed and saudi for
two years without charges
and this guy is lives in isolation
basically fighting
you know the kingdom for freedom of
speech
you uh you know you understand
the truth behind this and want to do
something about it is you see
you know the members of the g20 and the
trump administration essentially bury
their head in the stand and stand
and condone this murder all for all for
money
um and so hopefully in the construction
of the film
being a thriller that it also leads to
um a greater emotional response and that
was kind of the intention
yeah i mean i knew the story i had read
some of his pieces in
in the washington post i had a
familiarity with kind of the
the broader brushstrokes of what had
transpired what i was not aware of
was one focus of the film
being on on the extent of their
surveillance state and
how you know the the pegasus malware and
the hacking of the phones and how all of
that like played into
how that how this whole thing unfolded
you know to back up
um
khashoggi entered the consulate on um on
october 2nd
basically two weeks later i think it was
the 16th
um saudi arabia finally admitted that he
had
in fact died inside that consulate
and um in the film there's kind of the
whole story of
how that kind of unfolds
and the pressure that turkey put on
saudi arabia
to get them to ultimately confess
because they had the audio
and i had been following this story
essentially from october 3rd you know
washington post journalist
um vanishes inside of you know saudi
consulate in istanbul
and i'm reading this story as i think
many in the world were began following
this story in those two weeks and
you know each day it was another
shocking
uh um allegation
and that he had been dismembered
and that the body was nowhere to be
found and that they won't let him in the
consulate and
they're met with a few crazier and
crazier excuses on behalf of the kingdom
about what had happened yeah and and i'm
reading this
and um i remember because it was
uh i i'm pretty sure it was october 16th
17th and i was in
uh i was in rome at the time i had been
invited to speak
for the roman film festival
and i was with my fiancee and
i'd been following the story and as i
started following that story in those
two weeks in my mind i was going
maybe this is the next film i want to
make
this seems to have all these ingredients
because i've been looking
at that point for about the a year for
what that next
story i wanted to take on what that next
documentary i wanted to make was and i
felt
kind of a lot of pressure and burden
coming out of icarus that
i wasn't going to go and direct a disney
film i couldn't go
you know whatever uh make the stevie
wonder documentary or whatever that was
you know like
yeah like i was gonna have to at least
in my mind i wanted to see to it that i
was taking on something that was
human rights freedom of press freedom of
journalism
protecting a whistleblower authoritarian
regimes
dictatorships all these kind of themes
that
that is a as a storyteller
i wanted to be able to continue uh
in in that path and here was a story
of a journalist and not only that he's a
washington post journalist oh and he's
uh fighting for free speech and he's
advocating for human rights
and he disagrees with his authoritarian
government
and he's at essentially war awards with
you know with the crown prince and now
he's been murdered
and and i said okay
this could be the one and the question
was is can i
essentially get access to
this story to be able to tell it in a
matter that isn't going to be
something that's archival and there were
three things that really hinged on it
which was one
there was the story of his fiancee
emerging
of the girl you know attitude jengas was
waiting for him outside the consulate
and i said oh wow this is clearly the
emotional cord of what this story is i
mean
the the concept i mean which is
unfathomable to me it's unfathomable to
anybody listening to this that that
uh the person that you love that you
believe you're going to marry and spend
your life with
walks into a consulate an embassy you
know
uh to be murdered horrifically
and that you're never going to see them
again
and then at the same time become
in haditha's case the center of a global
media storm
uh and so all of a sudden you become
famous
and famous around the world to the point
where you can't really even leave your
house
not because of something you did that
you're proud of
but because the the person that you
loved
um has met this horrific fate
and that to me was the first element
that if i could get heteisha to work
with me
exclusively and share her story the love
story
that there would be a chance of being
able to really tell this story this the
second part of this was
omar abdulaziz in canada and in the days
following khashoggi's murder um
uh and uh the admission that saudi
arabia
uh you know that he had died inside that
consulate there's a story coming forward
in the new york times
of this young saudi dissident who was
living in montreal and
abdul aziz and he was saying
i know why jamal was killed in fact
i was hacked by
israeli cyber surveillance software
called pegasus
owned by the nso corporation and
that saudi arabia had hacked my phone
using this software pegasus jamal was
hacked too
and because my phone had been hacked
they knew that
jamal khashoggi and i had been working
on a project
to basically take over the narrative
back onto twitter as
you'll see in the film and if you read
about this saudi arabia basically was
manipulating and still to this day
manipulating twitter
which was the only platform in the
kingdom where people could have
freedom of speech and opinion because
twitter is a decentralized platform and
if you create like
different various twitter accounts and
you can create an account under a fake
name or whatever you want right
you can voice expression and this was
how the arab spring came to pass also
and a big argument for why anonymity on
twitter
is something to be protected so these
dissident voices can be heard
exactly and 80 sorry to interrupt
80 the point that you make that i also
didn't know is that 80
of saudi arabians are on twitter whereas
in the united states it's like 20
or something yeah so twitter
because the the platform is this kind of
decentralized information platform
and because you can kind of whatever you
can have a vpn you can create a twitter
account
under whatever your name is bugsbunny21
right it has become
on a global level in repressive
authoritarian regimes
ways that kind of like the resistance
can communicate with each other
and the arab spring only was able to
happen because of twitter
because they were able to plan events
they were able to plan marches plan you
know
and twitter became that platform
for dissidents to basically assemble
and what these authoritarian regimes
learned and
these arab governments in the case of
saudi arabia
you know basically a dictatorship a
monarchy
which is similar as it is in the
emirates and
uh and in egypt even though it's now you
know
uh it's technically not a monarchy but
it's but it's a dictatorship
um is is that if you could control
twitter if you could control the
narrative on twitter
you could crush freedom of speech you
could crush
opinion and that you can put forward
your propaganda
i mean you even see this as happened in
the trump administration over the last
four years where trump has used the
authoritarian playbook of
using twitter to basically bring forward
false information
whether it's about election fraud
whether about
you know voter fraud whether it's about
you know you name it trump has used
twitter
as his platform to disseminate false
information lies right well
these governments understand that
twitter can be used for that
and so saudi arabia puts together a plan
to basically hire thousands and
thousands and thousands of people in the
kingdom
to create false twitter accounts
and put forward onto twitter these false
goals of the kingdom
muhammad bin salman is a great reformer
muhammad bin salman's vision 2030 is the
best thing to ever happen to saudi
arabia
saudi arabia is this this this and this
right and so
twitter is being flooded unbeknownst to
the saudi people
with tens and tens of thousands of false
tweets
all pro-government all basically you
know
pushing forward this narrative and at
the same time saudi arabia is spending
you know uh depending on who you talk to
hundreds of millions and billions of
dollars
with global pr agencies with the same
thing
that muhammad bin salman is the greatest
thing to ever happen to saudi arabia
right
well omar abdulaziz
realizes that this is
what is happening on twitter in saudi
arabia is not real
these accounts are not real these are
fake accounts
these are accounts basically owned and
controlled by the government of saudi
arabia
to put forward false opinions and lies
and and
you know and false narratives about the
kingdom at the same time
what these accounts are doing is that
anybody like let's say omar abdulaziz or
jamal khashoggi
puts forward a tweet saying i disagree
with muhammad bin salman
i think this that these
saudi twitter trolls or flies this army
of
thousands tens of thousands of people
that have been hired
to basically take control of twitter all
of a sudden
flood this dissenters or you know
person's twitter account with screw you
you should die this isn't true right and
so suddenly their tweet is completely
suppressed like it doesn't exist
and everything that is trending in the
kingdom on on saudi arabia
is pro-government pro-monarchy pro-mbs
so jamal and omar are working on
basically a plan
that they call the bees army to take
control of the flies
where they're going to basically do the
same thing that the saudis have been
doing on twitter
except they're going to get dissidents
within the kingdom and everywhere
for them to create tons and tons of fake
twitter accounts but their fake twitter
accounts will be basically putting
forward freedom of speech human rights
right and that and that ultimately this
will be the war
between the bees and the flies right
that two can play at this game
you want to put forward your false
propaganda all right
we'll put forward the truth and we'll
you know tell the people what's really
happening
so because omar's phone is hacked with
pegasus
and because jamal's phone is hacked with
saudi arabia knows what these two are up
to and that they are basically trying to
reclaim control
of twitter and this arguably
is the biggest probably single reason
why they decide to murder jamal
because it's one thing that jamal is
writing in the washington post which was
negative
but it's another thing if all of a
sudden he and omar and this army
of dissidents basically can take
back control of twitter and twitter is
the way
that saudi arabia gets their news
this is so fundamental to the kingdom
in their narrative and in the hacking of
the phone
they're able to understand that jamal is
not only just
writing in the washington post they're
able to understand that he's now
working with a known dissident
to take back control of twitter and i
think that this was
probably the breaking point where they
decided that he needed
to be murdered and they had tried to
come to canada and rendition omar right
just months earlier those two dudes show
up and try to cajole him into returning
with promises that he'll get his own tv
show and that mbs loves him
but it's khashoggi who's saying don't do
that you don't want you don't want to do
that it's a trap
that's right and and yet khashoggi falls
into the same trap
and and he falls into the same trap and
you know the backs up so they had
[Music]
agents basically came to canada uh
with omar's brother in tow
basically as like a hostage you know
like hey omar
if you don't come back to saudi arabia
uh
and you know uh we love you which of
course was not true at all
you know uh just know that we've got
your brother
and omar chooses not to go back to saudi
arabia
and uh and after making that decision
they uh arrest his brothers
um 19 years old and
the other brothers a couple years older
and
they have remained in a saudi imprisoned
tortured
without charges for the last two years
and 33 of his friends
just people that were linked to him not
dissidents nothing just
just by knowing omar as basically this
rendition tool of hey if you want your
brothers
to get out of jail if you want your
friends to get out of jail
you need to either be silent
you know or you need to come back to
saudi arabia
where you know you're either going to be
imprisoned or
be silenced right um and so that
omar has not happened that omar has
continued to fight so
um yeah as he's still doing his youtube
show i mean i
i checked his twitter account last night
he's got
over a half million people now yeah he's
got a half a million followers and
and what happens on his youtube show is
every time he posts an episode
the kingdom uh and their lawyers
basically say that
whatever it is there's like he's using
copyrighted material he's using
uh they get it like things and they get
it pulled down and so then he has to put
it up somewhere else and they get it
pulled down
but if you go on to his youtube station
you'll see that you know it gets pulled
down it goes back up
and there's i don't know hundreds of
thousands of followers
uh that watch his essentially show
um which is kind of like a um
i don't know how you would best describe
it a a colbert kimmel
and you know it's like where's possum
youssef did in egypt
are you familiar with him he was sort of
the jon stewart of egypt
i've heard the name leading up to arab
spring he lives in in the us now and
he's been on the podcast but it's a
similar kind of situation
yeah we're where where omar is the first
guy to kind of create a show which is
criticizing the kingdom making jokes
he's taking kind of like
looking at like u.s style talk shows
right
and um and does this show
uh as often as he can looking at all the
saudi
daily news and looking at all the saudi
twitter feeds and all the
false narratives that he puts together
this show going like okay that's a lie
that's a lie that's a lie that's a lie
that's a lie that's a lie that's alive
and and also weaves in a lot of comedy
into it and is doing like
even like sketches and things like that
and correct me if i'm wrong but
but jamal's murder seems to almost
perfectly coincide
with the bees actually succeeding in
getting
their their message and their hashtags
to trend number one on twitter like
those
seem to almost happen at the exact same
moment
simultaneously yeah yeah and that
and i don't believe that that was an
accident
um it was
as this was taking steam i think the
decision
was made within the kingdom of we're
going to
we're going to send a message
and uh and when you understand that
that their phones were hacked right
um then then as you'll see in the film
and
and understanding the story behind this
um
you can see how that that danger grew
and
i think you know jamal
couldn't imagine he couldn't believe
that
his own country could do that to him
and he had actually went um
about a a month before
his murder because he was going back and
forth between washington dc
and istanbul where he's now uh with this
with hattija jenga yeah lives there
right right
and so they had decided that they were
going to have a life in both places
he bought an apartment or a condo for
them in istanbul
and they were going to split their time
they're going to be together in istanbul
then she'd come to washington
and study and she you know you go back
to istanbul so
he had bought a place for them in
istanbul
and he had originally went to the
consulate in washington dc
and actually met with um the u.s
ambassador at the time to the saudi
ambassador to the u.s at the time
who was muhammad bin salman's brother
right
and he goes into the consulate in
washington d.c
uh asking for these marriage papers
and they said we're happy to give you
these papers no problem at all
but you need to get a munis temple
you know you want to marry a turkish
woman you need to get him at the
consulate
in istanbul right so he comes out this
meeting in washington
kind of being welcomed he's you know met
with the prince's brother who he already
knew
right and he's assured everything's fine
no big deal you just need to go get him
in istanbul so when he goes into the
consulate in istanbul the first time
they welcome him they're nice to him but
they say oh hey we need to prepare these
papers
but they knew that he was going to be
coming to that consulate in istanbul
already you know so they go okay now we
got a shot at them
um so because they were they weren't
going to do it
on americans exactly right they weren't
going to do it on american soil and the
two
the the like bifurcation like you you're
gonna have to come back in five days
allowed them to get their plan in motion
and get these guys out from the kingdom
to be in the consulate when he arrived
exactly but he was nervous like he
brought hadisha with him
the first time both times because he he
wasn't quite certain that it was going
to be okay
well not only that he left his
phones and his computer
and everything with hatisha because
the both times that he went in
he basically left everything with with
her and said hey
if something happens to me um
here's wada khan far's information
here's jason aktai's information
here you know here's these people to
call
and so you know he goes in the first
time and they're nice to him they're
warm to them
and they say no problem jamal will give
you the paperwork we just need a few
days
come back in a week and so he leaves
kind of going okay
everything's okay right and that gives
them this week to essentially
plan his murder
and he goes back a week week later and
when he uh was was murdered and
but clearly you know i mean him leaving
his devices
with aetesia was even on his return back
in he
there was i'm sure that part of him
going like okay
here's my phone here's my this and and
in the
transcript of his murder
which we have in the film and
to this day that transcript has not been
released there's only a few people in
the world that have it it's
cia british intelligence the french
the turks of course and me uh
and there's a whole story behind how i
finally obtained the transcript
and in this transcript um you know he
makes note
that he doesn't have his phones on him
he's asked to send
uh a message to uh his son telling him
that he's
okay and that if he doesn't hear from
him for a few days not to worry
and he doesn't you know have his phones
with him
and he even says my fiance or you know
is waiting for me outside um
and uh so those devices and his computer
and everything
uh were brought into evidence and i've
been told
uh that they did find pegasus on those
devices
the transcript is horrific i mean it's
just
it's gut-wrenching um what's interesting
is the saudis were able to uh
delay the investigation for something
like two weeks right i think it was the
15th of october before they finally let
the turks
into the consulate yeah they're abouts i
don't uh yeah
it was it was a good two weeks and yeah
and in those
two weeks of course they were able to
clean up right the murder scene
um and not quite as well as they should
have
everything hey okay before taking
examples we are just modifying
a
[Music]
they never found um
what what's interesting and and in in
the transcript also is in the
and i don't get into this in in the film
in great detail but
in the um five or six days from the time
he first enters
the consulate and then goes back and
returns
um saudi arabia puts this mission into
kind of high motion
and they actually bring
two different teams there ahead of the
murder one of the teams
two days before he's murdered is to
sweep the consulate for listening
devices for bugs
and they don't find one and
the listening device was only in this
one room where they had secure
communications
and we still don't know to this day how
that listening device got there
whose device it was was it the turks was
it another country who handed it over to
the turks
not sure that's super interesting
because yeah that's never explained in
the film and i never heard an
explanation for who recorded it
and the turks will never tell you how
they got it uh-huh you know
that prosecutor is like a badass
he is like out of like a bond film isn't
it and his accent
is like unbelievable i mean he is every
filmmaker's dream
and the uh
you know he's never spoke on camera
about the crime to this day i don't
think there's a single interview out
there
of him other than what you'll see in the
dissident
and you know i think he carries a heavy
burden
um with with this case in particular
in the wake of all of this becoming
global news
you have mbs back in the kingdom
trying to figure out how he's going to
control this narrative
that is quickly eluding his ability to
manipulate
right which gets us into the pegasus
hack of
of bezos phone which is fascinating
we all remember when you know his his
personal pictures got leaked was it the
post the new york times uh
yeah uh it was the uh um
like the inquirer i was in choir
and um and basically
uh there are stories coming out that
bezos is having an affair
and that uh and that there's photos that
were
essentially going to be you know
published of like selfies that he had
sent to
lauren sanchez and uh there was even
apparently a nude or you know and then
he
pulls like the baller move of the
century by getting ahead of it and
making all of that available
right to anybody he basically puts
together this post on
uh medium going uh here's what's
happened
uh i was hacked uh my phone was hacked
um and i'm
not going to be blackmailed and they
were trying to blackmail me
and this is all a blackmail extortion
attempt because
i own the washington post and the saudis
are mad at me
uh because they saudi arabia
to back up bezos on the washington post
and
and in the fallout of the murder of
jamal khashoggi right
uh khashoggi wrote for the post so the
post has the biggest
knife in the fight and they are pushing
this story forward
and and the fascinating thing behind the
khashoggi murder but what
got the world involved was had
jamal been painted in the press in the
media as
saudi journalists enters consulate in
istanbul killed
right it would have fallen on deaf ears
but because it's an american paper the
you know
new york times washington post right and
they're putting forward this story that
it's not just a it's not saudi
journalists
it's a washington post journalist so now
jamal is essentially an american
and this catches the world's attention
had he not
been a washington post journalist
because in all the news it wasn't saudi
journalists it was washington post
journalist and here's this publication
that he had worked for
right and that's what caught the world's
attention it was a washington post
journalist and so what
mbs couldn't you know
um i guess separate in his mind is the
idea that you can own a newspaper
and not have control of the newspaper
right right
so just because you own the new york
times
doesn't mean in the united states that
you control the new york times
if you're a free paper right you don't
have control over what the paper
actually writes you can
you know i'm sure there's whatever i
mean for fox news it's basically putting
forward its thing but
ultimately there is still a freedom
oppressed there
so the washington post is pushing this
forward
the story forward globally and making
the khashoggi murder
you know a huge huge global story
they're running
ads in the paper full page ads in the
paper behind the murder
they're putting up billboards they are
you know the washington post is not
letting this story die
and nbs in his mind is going well hey
jeff bezos you own the washington post
you can make this stop
yeah kill it and behind the scenes those
guys had been
in communication with each other because
mbs was trying to get
amazon up on its feet in the kingdom
right so they
had they had business dealings together
there was a whole deal for uh
i don't know billions of dollars of a
cloud server that
amazon was gonna do with the kingdom
and um and lo and behold
mbs hacks bezos's phone with pegasus
but um or we think it's pegasus
but he had actually been hacked before
the khashoggi murder
so he had been sending bezos's messages
and all of a sudden bezos gets this
video message of like a soccer match
and saudi arabia versus i can't remember
norway
and bezos clicks on this message and
it's like
how what is this message you know he's
kind of
perplexed by it but lo and behold
that was hacking his phone
and so in the fallout of the khashoggi
murder
as all of a sudden bezos's affair is
being leaked to the public
you know bezos brings on an
investigation team
of you know forensic cyber examiners
who go into his devices and they're
watching the data stream out of his
phone right
and linking it to a server known
to be a saudi server you know
and so you know you go okay well
how else was this information coming
public
uh it was clear that that you know that
he had been hacked
um and uh yeah so you know you go okay
if you can hack the richest man in the
world
who right i mean that's the kind of
scary
message that you leave everyone with
like nobody is
out of bounds here nobody is
out of bounds and and i think one of the
the themes in the film and
um is
the battlegrounds the of the world right
now
are not being fought with weapons
it's being fought in cyber
sphere and these are the biggest weapons
in the world right now you look at the
nepetia virus
a couple years ago in the ukraine that
was a russian virus that shut down the
entire
power grids in the ukraine and basically
completely
hobbled the ukraine and all these major
shipping companies andy greenberg writes
about this in his book called sandworm
and a lot of people don't know this
story but this was the single biggest
cyber
attack in the world's history so far
against ukraine because it crippled
all the global shipping agencies that
crippled fedex and basically infected
their systems
and brought down you know these
companies to their knees for this period
of time
and cost billions and billions of
dollars
and to this day people don't even
realize what happened and this was a
cyber attack
or in the case of these
cyber firms like nso is what you read
and what you learn is that there is
hacking software
you know there was an idea a few years
ago okay you know apple and the
government trying to get apple to turn
over codes and stuff
they don't need that anymore there's now
private software
being developed by private companies in
this case this is a company called
nso out of israel all of these
sales have to get approved by the
israeli government
but israel basically is allowing the
sale
of this software to pretty much any
government in the world
because when they sell this software
israeli intelligence
is also gaining insight into who each
one of these companies wants to
hack you know so okay say israel
and nso sells pegasus to the saudis
right and you go why would israel
want saudi arabia to have this hacking
technology
well not only is lucrative and they're
paying millions of dollars per
you know for these licenses but on the
back end right
nso and israeli intelligence
are able to know who saudi arabia is
hacking
who they're after what they're in touch
so so i mean it's just
it's it's it's really nutty but what you
understand is that this
technology is also now in private hands
and much like with snowden you know
unveiled to the world
um you know with what
uh you know our
uh government was doing and what the nsa
was doing in in in listening into
people's devices
and you know and all the information he
brought forward
what you're seeing is that this is even
much
worse than we can imagine because
governments around the world
essentially with just somebody's phone
number
can go in and hack somebody's device
take control of that device
know everything about that person and
this is and this is
a completely unregulated part
of of the cyber landscape that there is
no regulation
in this regard other than you know the
united states knows that the saudis have
this technology and they know the
emirates have this technology and the
emirates knows that you know
other countries have this technology and
the ability to destabilize geopolitics
and do it essentially invisibly is so
potent
and frightening right and what what's
interesting about this is it shares a
common theme with with icarus
in that this search for a competitive
advantage um creates a situation in
which
the advantage is always ahead of the
detection method
right in the sense that doping is always
kind of two steps ahead of our ability
to detect it and creates this
you know this sort of tension between
those two
competing entities here we have cyber
warfare just
miles ahead of our ability to even
understand it let alone
preemptively get in front of it yeah i
mean that's an interesting analogy i
never really
thought about it that way um and that's
a
really uh good and interesting analogy
which is
um i think what we see as a society in
technology
is every time we have this a newer
technology another thing unleashed
it's incredible in some sense and on the
same hand
it's that more invasive and invasive
technique and
you can look at this across all these
platforms even like
like google right okay so google buys
nest cameras right and so now if you
have a nest camera
the only way to actually have other
people
have access to the nest is to integrate
it in through
google home right but your google home
account
is linked to your gmail account and your
gmail
account and your google account is
linked to all your web searches and
everything i mean
so you go oh my god what kind of
information does google
have on me they have access to my home
they have access to my cameras they have
access
you know if your ring or nest right they
have access to
my security systems they have access to
my web searches they have access to my
emails
right and so you have a these companies
you know whether that's facebook and
instagram and i mean
the other day i i was literally thinking
of going and uh
um you know uh taking taking taking a
trip
and was trying to figure out where to go
and uh
and um you know i did a search for like
the bahamas right
and all of a sudden on my instagram
yesterday
i'm getting ads yeah uh about
resorts in the bahamas were they going
what yeah why on my instagram feed
are resorts in the bahamas coming up and
yet
there they are the scarier thing is when
you just say it out loud you don't do a
search and then you get the ads
right siri google assistant
all that stuff so you know you have like
sonos speakers and you hook it up to
your google assistant you go
hey google play led zeppelin yeah right
and then the next thing you're doing
you're saying buy the led zeppelin
right you know box set when you uh
when you interviewed the cyber security
expert dude that
that kind of figured out that omar's
phone had been hacked did you have him
look at your phone
uh john railton scott yes yeah um yeah
i've had my devices
um looked at um
[Music]
i have a monitoring
device on my phone which is actually uh
hopefully would show if all of a sudden
my phone starts
pinging towers that it isn't supposed to
to ping so the way that they look
to figure out if you've been hacked
right
is it's not like oh you've got some
virus
in your phone and like i think the way
that most people think about
oh i've been hacked or i'm getting you
know malware of crashing
the way that cyber security experts
look um at where you've been if you've
been hacked
is apparently our phones
really only communicate to a handful
and i don't know what that handful is
whether that's 100 200 whatever it is
kind of global satellites and servers
you know
google and uh
and apple and amazon and all these
different
servers and satellites that essentially
are in control
of all data and communications right so
your phone is pinging
like this satellite right or pinging
this
this server connected to a satellite
whatever the
technical thing of it i'm messing up but
right
but it's not that many like so okay if
we're going on
amazon right it's it's going there or
no matter what that search is because
our search engines right
it's like okay it's google it's safari
it's
uh whatever that is firefox or something
like that and so everything that we're
doing on our phones
or our apple or our androids right right
or ultimately going through these
different
massive infrastructure you know
servers satellites so the way that they
figure out if you've been hacked
is if all of a sudden there's
information coming from your phone
to essentially a satellite server
right that is not part of one of these
big servers because there's no reason
why your phone
would be communicating with that
server and if and if what they're
watching when they
are looking at your phone is all of a
sudden you have data being extracted
out of your phone that your uploads are
much more than your downloads because
why would your uploads be more than your
downloads right
right you're downloading information
yeah not
uploading information out of your phone
and it's communicating with one of these
servers
which they don't know that's how
they're looking at whether or not a hack
has happened
well it would seem relatively elementary
to have an
app that could run a diagnostic on that
and let you know if something is awry
well
it's more complicated than that now
because basically
um you would need to as as
like john relton scott who um is the
citizen lab in canada and they're
and they're the ones who figured out
that omar had been hacked with pegasus
and the way that they figured out that
omar
had been hacked with pegasus and they
actually are
you know one of the people if not the
people that discovered
pegasus um and they've published
um other hacks of pegasus and other
people who've been targeted and
if you go in and research you know uh
the citizen lab
uh out of canada out of um out of
toronto the monk school
in toronto's where they're they're
funded um
is they in their research
were basically looking
at you know information streaming to
these servers that they identified
um as not being part of you know
all these ones that are legitimate right
where your traffic would flow from apple
right
or google um and in identifying these
servers
they were able to start identifying uh
the use of these servers
and and so in the case of omar you when
they got his device
they were seeing that essentially there
was a device in canada
right communicating with one of these
servers
that they had deemed to be owned
to be a saudi server that they believe
was using
you know pegasus software um
and so i guess the the back end of this
is
understanding what all these servers are
where they are and then they're always
changing too so that
so the game kind of like the doping
thing that you say is that it's always
it's you're only as good as you were
today but if a new substance comes out
right that's
unable to avoid detection or a new super
drug
right well you wouldn't test positive
even though you're
positive because it's undetectable which
is
much like okay you're going to test for
breast cancer right
well the test for breast cancer is
this test right you're going to test
this this and this and if
and if that doesn't show up then well
then you don't have breast cancer
but if there's a new strain of breast
cancer which they haven't developed to
test for or that they don't know about
yet right
you would test negative for breast
cancer even though you might have breast
cancer mm-hmm
hypothetically or for anything right the
same applies
to doping in you know substances
and that you're only gonna you know you
can't detect something unless you're
being tested
for that and the same in the world of
cyber and hacking is that okay they're
gonna plug in all the known variables
but if there's a new variable a new
server a new technology a new right
they're not going to know if you've been
hacked yeah it is really frightening
unbelievably yeah yeah amazingly in the
wake of all of this
we see uh politicians
uh you know standing up calling for you
know action to do the right thing and
we're talking about people like lindsey
graham
and rand paul right and yet
we then see you kind of conclude the
film with you know trump vetoing
any any kind of deleterious action that
would
that would harm the kingdom well
so where does that leave us like
geopolitically like what do you make of
how
this whole thing kind of shook out well
to
backtrack into that um
what we see in in in the film
is that um there has been no
punishment for saudi arabia for the
murder of jamal khashoggi
there has been no meaningful sanctions
taken not only in the united states
but by all members of the g20
and what we see was there was bipartisan
support from
both the republicans and the democrat to
have sanctions to stop
weapon sales to saudi to basically
um you know attempt to stop the war in
yemen
um and that ultimately the trump
administration
vetoed all these actions and in bob
ordered's
book that he just published where he had
recorded all these conversations with
trump
trump actually flat out said and has
said i
saved mbs's ass so this is actually
something that trump is
proud of that he basically uh
protected the relationship uh with
himself
or the united states however you want to
look at it in saudi arabia
by not punishing muhammad bin salman
for the murder of jamal khashoggi or in
stopping weapon sales or standing up
against some warren yemen so you know
this is something that you know the
trump administration is very proud of
despite what you've seen as bipartisan
support
in the united states to basically take
action to reassess
the u.s relationship with saudi arabia
joe biden actually on the second year
anniversary of
jamal's murder which just passed on
october
2nd put out a statement uh
saying you know if i'm elected president
he's now been elected president
um one of one of the things that i'll be
doing is
reassessing the u.s saudi relationship
looking at sanctions looking at action
and you know and he
basically sent out a tweet you know like
justice for jamal
um and even since he's been
president-elect he's
said again that he is planning to um
you know really dive into u.s saudi
relations
in light of all their human rights
abuses uh and what's happening
in the kingdom so there there appears to
possibly be
um some sort of positive outcome coming
from this
um but to date you have seen
no member state of the g20 and or the
united states
take any action against this and
this really just speaks to i think the
global economic relationship
of saudi arabia and the world um
unlike you know let's say a country you
know even like russia right
where the economic stakes are not as
high because of the investment
what we see out of the kingdom is
because
saudi arabia has the single largest
sovereign wealth fund
in the world meaning that they have more
money to
invest into other essentially
countries and buy stuff in any other
country
and they are so liquid in their
investments uh they're also basically
you know all the money in softbank the
world's largest hedge fund
is saudi money right that
not just governments but companies
around the world
don't know how to say no to the
investment
and in case of this film yeah which that
leads me into the question around
distribution of this movie and how you
financed it
we have uh we have fought a real uphill
battle
um the in the making of the film
uh the human rights foundation uh
thor halverson uh who started the
foundation gary kasparov is
its um is its ceo
um decided to fund the film
because the human rights foundation um
actually had invited jamal khashoggi to
one of its uh freedom forums called the
oslo freedom forum
that they host every year in oslo where
they bring together
uh dissidents from all over the world
that have either fled their countries
or are escaped from their countries or
you know to come and speak about these
oppressive regimes and what's going on
in their country
and so the work of the human rights
foundation
aligns with this film
and they have helped to fund and give
voice to dissidents all over the world
from oppressive regimes and fighting for
freedom of speech and democracies
and uh and whether it's the
you know the ugars in in china
uh or whether it's what's been going on
in venezuela
or whether it's you know oppression in
russia
or you know you name it um
the human rights foundation uh and their
mandate is basically
um to try to protect human rights and
freedom of speech and democracies
and fight against authoritarian
dictatorships and so
um when i decided i wanted to make this
film
uh thor halverson and i met through a
mutual friend
and he said i i actually met jamal he
was
at the oslo freedom forum back in may
and he was murdered in october
and um you know uh we've been talking to
omar abdulaziz to
invite him to an oslo freedom forum and
iyad al-baghdadi who you see in the film
was a
another dissident actually has spoken
many times at the also freedom forums
and involved with the human rights
foundation
you know um we'd love to we'd love to do
this
and so they came in and uh and backed
the film
and had been my partners in making the
film
and uh we premiered the film at
sundance uh which it's so crazy that
that was
nine ten months ago and it was just
before covid
right it was like the last whole thing
it was just before
it was literally yeah exactly as soon as
you got home clamp down boom
and uh apparently sundance now turns out
to be like a
super spreader event right right that's
right and um
at our premiere there is uh hillary
clinton came to the premiere
and alec baldwin and um
and each time we show at sundance we
have standing ovations
um and the most incredible
reviews i've i've ever read from you
know the the trades and the critics that
were there
uh i was really taken back by them and
um and we come out of sundance on you
know the
top 10 films of the hollywood reporter
in the top 10 variety in the top eight
of ap
and all these you know incredible
accolades
to not a single offer of distribution
not one that speaks louder than words
not a
penny being offered for the film
not a dollar nothing
that is so correct and here is
you know the company that i did icarus
with that i believe is my partners
silence here's amazon and jeff bezos and
me believing that well
bezos would have a knife in this fight
yeah you think he'd be the number one
choice silence
and every one of the major global
streamers global media
entertainment company studios that could
have acquired
and given life to this film silence
and what we see here
is essentially that the dollar
the saudi investment the
potential to grow in that a region to
gain subscribers into saudi arabia and
here you know netflix took off hassan
minaj's
show for criticizing mbs
they pulled like a whole episode right
they pulled a whole episode and just a
few weeks ago they announced
an eight-slate deal uh with saudi arabia
and is is saudi arabia invested in
netflix
are they an equity partner in that
company i have no idea
but i i i think what we see and it
speaks
not just to netflix it's not it's
it's across the board
is that um human rights and freedom of
speech
isn't just in in danger and being
suppressed
in places like saudi arabia it's here in
the united states
where essentially our economic interests
and these interests of these massive
companies
that have the ability to disseminate
information that have the ability
for a global audience to see something
and
learn and take action and stand up
against forces like this and bring about
change
are choosing their business interests
and economic interests and their
shareholder interests
over what their audiences actually
would want to see um
or would want to see on top of seeing
love is blind
um and so it's a it's a it's a very
um we're in a moment here where these
companies have grown
so big and so powerful and we're in this
huge
global landscape whereas years ago
you could go okay hey you're a company
and you're just distributing the film
for the united states
right so you're like okay we can put
this out in the united states no problem
but now the formula is is global
and so nobody wants to put something out
with the idea that
oh you might upset china you might upset
um russia you might upset saudi you
might upset
egypt you might upset brazil you might
wherever you call it
and so the appetite for content
that actually is taking on subject
matter such as this
over the last couple years has been
completely and utterly
diminished and and these companies
are now operating much in the way
of like a government where
you're going okay do we punish the
murder
of alexander lithanenko well if we do
that what are we doing are we sending
are we starting a war with russia no
we're not going to do that are we going
to stop doing business with russia no
we're not going to do that
are we going to sanction russia to the
tune of gazillions of dollars
so that it hurts our economies no we're
not going to do that so ultimately we go
all right
we'll let you get away with murdering
this dissident
on foreign soil and
just like what has happened in the
khashoggi murder where essentially
they've been able to get away with it
because of the
amount of money in business and and
investment
we're seeing this stretch way beyond
governments and it's now
in these media companies and
corporations where
a couple months ago amazon announced
that they were
acquiring souk souq was essentially the
amazon of saudi arabia
right right so now amazon owns souk
so amazon controls right commerce in the
kingdom commerce in the kingdom
and so ultimately the decision was okay
acquire the dissident or
continue our billions of dollars of
business that we're going to do in the
kingdom yeah it's not doing the business
it's not a difficult economic decision
to make and it's amazing
that we can all rally around
uh a free speech issue when it's
confronted with
with you know uh um a government
that is you know trying to clamp down on
it through you know
by way of of laws right but here we are
in the west
where we technically have freedom of
speech and yet economic interests are
creating
this unbelievable chilling effect on the
free exchange of ideas and it's
happening right underneath our eyes
we're seeing this progressive
restriction as a result of those
economic tectonic plates but also
from the people themselves it's like
we're we're policing ourselves when it
comes to free speech so it's a very
different
conversation around free speech than
that which
you know we're talking about when we
look at places like
saudi arabia well i i have um
many friends who will go unnamed that
had
various projects in development with
these major media companies that
looked at things from
[Music]
you know on human rights levels on
uh political levels on
stories such as this and that these
global streamers
have all basically said no we're not
going to do these stories anymore
i have heard stories of unnamed
companies but among these companies that
basically have had shareholder meetings
where they have discussed in these
meetings that anything that is political
anything that uh were to you know
uh take on the trump administration or
were to take on china or to
you know go against you name it we're no
longer interested in
and and the reason being is because
the growth in these regions right
is more important than the human rights
in these regions
and so you know ultimately if you can
expand let's say and have
millions of subscribers in saudi arabia
a wealthy country
and have all this revenue from saudi
arabia versus
showing these awful human rights abuses
in the country
well you're going to take the money uh
over what is ethics and morality and i
think it's been a
it's been a rude awakening to me
as a filmmaker and as and as an activist
to think that
this is kind of happening because i i
view that
in that those who have wealth and power
in a perfect world and especially in the
western world
should be the ones who are standing up
and having the strength to shed light
for the world into places where people
are being oppressed or suppressed
and just like you see with the nba in
china
or espn in china being able to walk away
from all these abuses
or what china's been doing in hong kong
yet all these
companies are still doing business with
china despite them trying to turn
hong kong into you know into into
a dictatorship right and yet
nobody's willing to stop doing business
with them
and and uh
we're seeing this across the board and
it's disheartening
for someone like me who wants to
continue to make films like this and
bring stories like this forward
having to struggle to
have this content seen
and and i would have thought that
having had the honor of winning an
academy award
would have changed that right giving you
a little bit more
latitude and doors swinging wide open at
netflix
you would think um
but that is not the case and then on the
other hand
you can see this from a company's
perspective
right you watch in the dissident how
jeff bezos is able to be hacked you
watch how somebody is able to be chopped
up and murdered
so if you're that company right on the
flip side you can imagine those internal
conversations of going like
i don't want them to hack us i don't
want them to hack my company
i don't want them to take down my
servers i don't
want them to launch a twitter campaign
against us
i don't want it you know right and not
that you need to covet favor with mbs
but no need to antagonize him when
there's so much business opportunity to
be had potentially in the future
right and there's so much risk to be had
by taking that on right
and and i think that that equation
um ultimately i don't think the word is
bad decision making
i think leads into risk assessment
analysis
and each one of these companies are
corporations there's risk assessment
and that risk assessment announcement is
okay on one hand
whatever hundreds of millions of people
will see the film and
they'll be accolades and it'll be the
set and the other on the other hand
maybe x y z can happen um
another filmmaker i admire ryan white
who did the keepers uh
did a film this year called assassins
and it's on the murder of kim jong-il's
uh
half-brother in malaysia by the two
women that basically
poison him at the airport right and you
go it's north korea
again ryan's film
nobody has stepped up on a global level
to distribute this
it's being distributed by a small
distributor
and i've never heard of it yeah that's a
great film
and again he was that sundance and the
story
is the exact story of a dissonant which
is
all of these global streamers and here
ryan had had tremendous success with the
keepers and netflix right
and uh and ultimately they went oh well
the sony hack right was the north
koreans
and that was really embarrassing for
sony and this was over a film b
interview which was a comedy and so all
these global streamers are going like
okay they hacked sony they messed them
up screw it
it doesn't matter that assassins is an
important film it doesn't matter that
it's insight into north korea
it doesn't matter that it shows how what
this is
not for us we don't want the risk
and um so i think there has to be a
reimagining for storytellers
um uh
or activists that want to see to it that
their content can be globally
seen and um and maybe a new platform is
ultimately
created that that allows us but the
counter to this
is um breyer cliff entertainment
tom ortenberg um who was running
uh lionsgate and then open road and
and did spotlight and did crash
and did fahrenheit 911 and
um has been a real champion for you know
for
for difficult films that you know uh
came forward uh you know about six
months ago
and uh acquired the film and
so the dissident we had planned that it
was gonna come out
into theaters it was gonna go on a
thousand screens
on october 2nd and of course with covid
that that wasn't going to happen
so then we changed the plan again to
december 18th and we're still in covit
so that's not happening
so now it's coming out in limited
theaters where theaters are open
december 25th
and on january 8th it will launch across
all
on-demand platforms where people can
rent the movie so
it will be on itunes it will be on
amazon for purchase it will be on
uh xbox and roku and fire stick and
comcast and
uh direct tv um and all those places so
i'm
so i'm optimistic that
you know it'll it'll find its way it
won't
it's not going to be in front of uh
you know a couple hundred million
subscribers
with a subscription in netflix but
it will make its way into the world yeah
it'll find its way and so the december
25th
limited release is you know on the
before the year turns over is for oscar
consideration right isn't that still the
thing
it has to premiere in a theatrical way
before
that's my understanding so right and
then it'll be available after that
january 8th and luckily our
our partnership with the um um i guess
they call it pvod paid on demand
um company vertical is
you know for for the longest time i
think it was
a 45 day window you couldn't if you
launched in a theater you couldn't have
it on demand within 45 days
but with covid right um all of the rules
are changing now and so we're able to
come into theaters on december 25th and
be available
uh for on demand on on
uh on january 8th so you know it's
excited for the film to to be seen
because i i really uh i just uh hatisha
jengas jamal's fiance i mean she's
become like a sister to me and for me
this film has
gone so far beyond um making a film
i i just feel so personally connected to
the story and
and as an activist um you know i'm still
uh involved in this on a daily basis
latisha came to sundance right
she came to sundance yeah she's still
living in istanbul
she's in assemble she had um she
got a place from washington dc was
starting her foundation to seek justice
for jamal
and then covet happened and she went
back to istanbul and she's been there
since so hopefully on the other side of
kovitch she'll
come back to washington and resume work
and
hopefully with the biden administration
there'll be a much
warmer reception to the advocacy and
human rights work that she's seeking to
do
where does the u.n sit with all of this
i mean a big part of the narrative of
the film is kind of
you know their their own sort of
investigation into what occurred and
then
haditha's testimony you know before the
council
but what is their power to do anything
and kind of where do they sit with the
whole affair well
this was a another kind of icarus
analogy if i could make
um is i had always viewed
um that the world anti-doping agency
had authority and what
i came to understand is that their job
is basically to just
observe and report and be lame duck and
that they basically can't do anything
they're like
the security guard in the neighborhood
who drives around but
is kind of feckless exactly they're the
guys that could literally go like
okay these guys are cheating but um yeah
we have no power to punish them
you know and and so that was the amazing
thing that i i saw
you know in in in in icarus and the
story of rachenkov and this cheating is
okay you have this
global regulator of world sport that
also has no power
to actually really do anything and enact
punishments
and that the power is actually within
the sporting federations themselves
and within the olympics and this that
the other and that wata is really just
the guy
out there is like the watchdog pointing
a finger but they're like a mall cop
right well i've found this same thing to
be the case of
with the un so in in
in the film um you see agnes calamart
who
is the who is a special repertoire
of the united nations she's a character
an investigator she's french
but she also teaches at columbia and
so on the outset you go okay agnes
is the u.n
she's actually not she's a special
repertoire to the united nations meaning
that she has been given permission
by the united nations to launch an
investigation
her own independent investigation under
the umbrella of the united nations
human rights committee but she doesn't
actually work for the u.n
she's like a contractor it's complicated
there's all these special repertoires of
the u.n of their different committees
that are able to launch investigations
that the u.n will either provide a
budget for
and then ultimately let them speak so
agnes does an entire investigation of
the khashoggi murder
presents her finding to the united
nations human rights
council but the human rights council is
kind of like
wada they're just there to observe and
report they have no
power right and the united states under
trump actually
removed themselves from the united nati
from the un
human rights committee if you can
imagine it the united states
no longer has a seat on the united
nations human rights
council how is that possible how is that
possible
trump pulled us out of the uh
but we're we're no longer part of the
united states that's outrageous human
rights
human rights council unbelievable
but saudi arabia is um
so so uh-huh so agnes presents her
finding to the khashoggi murders you see
in the film
to the united nations human rights
committee but
like water the only thing that they can
do is really observe and report
and ultimately the u.n the general
assembly the security council
have to take it up to do something about
it
and so the human rights committee
doesn't have the power
and uh and ultimately
despite the evidence despite the report
despite the intelligence and the cia and
british intelligence
and the transcript and the audio and
everything else the united nations
general assembly
the security council has not taken up
this investigation
and has not sanctioned saudi arabia and
has done nothing
to take action against saudi arabia and
not only that you saw the g20
just hosted you know uh
just weeks ago a week ago
in for in riyadh
so when hadija is testifying that's not
in front of the general assembly that's
in front of the human rights council and
you see
that's right the the saudi contingent
just basically get up and leave in the
middle of that
and there's no penalty for that or any
kind of repercussions
it was um it was startling and i think
again so
we were allowed which is kind of um
uh unheard of um to have a film camera
film cameras uh within the united
nations let alone at the
in in an official united nations you
know human rights
uh committee uh meeting
but uh we were connected through agnes
and we got in touch with their
communications office
and essentially they were like okay this
is important
we'll let you come film this and so we
were granted a very special permission
to go in there with our cameras to film
uh agnes testimony and hatisha
speaking in front of the united nations
you know
human rights committee asking for
justice for jamal
and as she goes to speak
the two saudis that were there
representing saudi arabia on this matter
literally get up and walked out the door
so that did happen that did happen at
that time because when i was watching i
was like i was wondering i was like i
wonder if brian edited
this to make it look like they got up in
the middle when actually they left at
the end
no wow that happened in
real time it was unbelievable
literally watching the saudis not only
deny
any responsibility say that this is a
saudi matter
but then hatisha goes to give her
two minutes i can't remember three
minutes
of of asking for justice and as she goes
to speak
the two saudi representatives get up and
walk out the door
it's insane insane wow
was there anybody that you wish you
could have interviewed on camera that
you just couldn't get to
that would have made the story um
no and i i
there was a question um
i don't go to saudi arabia for the film
and i don't i noticed that have you ever
been there
no and i don't interview any
uh saudi you know mbs or uh
or you know um uh
whatever uh did you ever reach out to
any of those guys like no and the reason
why
is um
much like icarus um
i had gregory rachankov rachenkov was a
whistleblower
his evidence was solid
the diaries everything that he had
brought forward was solid
had been proven forensically proven
through the mclaren report proven
through the new york times
proven i mean you know what i mean right
like the evidence is
when you look at what he brought forward
you there's no denying it's it is what
it is
and all the investigation surrounded it
proved it
so in this case of the khashoggi murder
right
what was important to me was to get the
evidence from the turkish which i got
hear about the investigation and why
this is a hundred percent to be believed
and there's an open and shut
case which is in the film
to get all of that to basically present
this story
in a way of you know the untold story
behind this murder
but to go and let's say interview
muhammad bin salman right
you already know what that interview is
did you do it
no did you know about it no who did it
i don't know i mean there was nothing to
be gained
by doing two things one alerting saudi
arabia that i was making the film
two trying to go to saudi arabia where
you know you're risking your life
and three basically bringing propaganda
and rhetoric into something
i didn't want to lend voice to that
because that's not
true so it to me
it was inconsequential to the narrative
of the film just like
okay let's say i would have been able to
interview putin
and ask him well i know what putin has
to say about gregory rachankov and the
allegations
you can watch his his conferences he's
made multiple statements
he said that gregory is a member of
u.s intelligence that he's a spy that he
is a traitor
that he is crazy that he belongs in a
mental asylum i mean
and you're not going to catch him in a
gotcha moment right it's all
well-documented so great so i go and
interview putin and what's he going to
tell me
he's going to tell me a i didn't do it b
these are a bunch of lies
and c gregory is insane i mean this is
so i already know what what mbs is going
to say
so what is the point of lending further
credence
to a false narrative when it's really
not what the story is
yeah it's going to be interesting to see
how everything plays out with mbs i mean
the arc being that he sort of originally
positions himself as somewhat of a
reformer and is able to kind of covet
global popular opinion then we kind of
see
that perhaps he's not that but he's got
his
um he's sort of planning his flag with
his vision
2030 and and this davos in the desert
thing that ends up becoming
kind of like a debacle right so on some
level
there's a backing up of the global
community who
is reticent to be you know too involved
with this guy and yet there's so much
money involved in so much opportunity
those two things being at odds with each
other like how does that play out does
the money always win
well um the year the
the davis davos in the desert is mbs's
annual
basically investment form uh to bring
together
world investment leaders ceos of major
you know fortune 500 and global
companies to basically come and
get investment from saudi arabia or to
put investment into saudi arabia
and two years ago
right after the khashoggi murder many of
these
corporations business leaders
governments whatever
didn't come to pulled out to riyadh they
pulled out
but they still set like their third in
charge fourth in charge you know
kind of uh what's what's that word
culpable deniability or something we
can't be seen
like but we actually still wanna [ __ ]
had a golden
fact sax couldn't be there but his third
in charge was there you know
i see um but
this past year um they all came back
they all came back so you know uh
the money's too big it's just
it's too much to walk away from the
investment is too big
the cash is too much and and
saudi arabia's future essentially relies
on
no longer being dependent on oil right
right
so uh in that regard nbs is
a great reformer meaning okay he
is a young prince he's 35 now right
34. and he realizes that the future of
his country
is basically not as being the world's
oil supplier as tesla
and you know electric cars and all this
stuff
is is gaining and gaining and gaining
and
companies like neo and china you know is
the tesla rival i mean their stock is up
i don't know
10 000 this year right so we see this
future
of energy unfolding and so
arguably over the next 10 20 years three
right
the reliance on oil is going to become
less and less and less
so the only way that saudi arabia can
survive is to take
all of these trillions of dollars yeah
this
massive liquidity and invest it globally
and put it to use globally
either to bring investment into the
kingdom or to invest
outside of the kingdom so that they have
major stakes in this company
or own you know whatever it is hundreds
of millions of shares of uber or
you know all these different investments
that they've made to either return
investment to the kingdom because
they're not going to get that from oil
anymore
or to bring investment into the kingdom
because
it can you know uh it can grow and also
to
educate the saudi people uh to
to basically be computer programmers to
be
to build to construct to to basically do
what what we've been doing here in the
united states and other and other
economies
so what you see in the uae right
and so and and saudi arabia and the uae
are best friends
nbc in many cases considered like
nbs's like you know right uh
godfather you know like that mbs takes
his direction
from nbc in the emirates
um so clearly mbs is
is right on that and that's part of
vision 2030 is how to basically
diversify the kingdom
one of the things he did was he brought
saudi aramco public
which there was a lot of
controversy over that because a lot of
people didn't think that
the state's oil company should be
brought public
but i mean they only sold like like five
percent of it
but in so doing overnight they created i
think it's the second most valuable
company in the world
apple i think has surpassed it now but
it's you know saudi aramco is worth like
i don't know 1.7 trillion wow or
something like that
but that was the ability for again for
others
to invest in saudi
in saudi arabia you look at these the
oil war that they created with
with russia this past year which has led
to this you know basically the
lowest oil prices we've seen in a
generation was again
basically how to infuse the kingdom with
cash
and uh and basically you know
expedite the their oil supply
um to basically flood money you know
it's just
these are all ways that um mbs
is trying to uh diversify the kingdom
and open it up to investment
and in many ways there's a lot of
positive things about this and
jamal khashoggi said that many of the
things that mbs was doing was positive
at the same hand you have lujan hatoul
the female activists who basically
advocated
for women to drive in saudi arabia on
trial
right now in saudi arabia and what is
she on trial for
she's on trial for basically freedom of
speech
even though now women are allowed to
drive in saudi arabia
because it was her idea and it was her
basically pushing this
she was arrested and she sat in a
in a prison for the last two years
tortured and her trial is now going on
in saudi arabia for i don't remember
what the exact charges are it's like
you know crimes against the state that
basically she has spoke
against the kingdom wow so even though
that's now
perpetuates today she's she's being
tried
yeah for basically instigating what is
now law
right it wasn't uh
you know uh so and and
and so this is continued so uh you know
it's a
it's it's complicated i was thinking off
subject for a second but
you talk about this um cyber
um threat and like pegasus
right and uh access the governments
or these companies you know can have
into our devices
and what's become clear to me which i
think we're going to see in the next
several months
is that not only is that technology here
all of us on planet earth are about to
have this on our phones
when you think about what's happened
with covid and coronavirus right
the only way out of this is a vaccine
and arguably the only way out of this
is that every single person on the
planet can prove that they've been
vaccinated
so how are we going to be able to prove
that we've been vaccinated
you can already see this there's going
to be an app
on our phones and every single place
where we go
whether it's a restaurant whether it's
an airport whether it's shopping at
costco
whether it's whole foods whether it's
walking into the door of the business
right
you're going to open up this app on your
phone they're going to scan it
it's going to show your photo there's
rich roll it's going to show the date he
was vaccinated
it's going to show when he was
vaccinated it's going to show that he's
covet negative
and then you're going to be allowed to
enter the premises well who's going to
control this app
our government yeah this is going to be
a national
international database
and i guarantee that as this vaccine
rolls out within the next five
six months or whenever this is the only
way
every single person on the planet in the
western world at least to begin with
will have to make a decision do we want
to go to a concert
do we want to go fly on a plane do we
want to go to a restaurant do we want to
go to a store do we want to go
into the market and the choice will be
yes or no
kind of much like you know what happened
in the in as
as christianity you know made its way
through the world which was
you know a gun or a knife to your head
do you accept jesus christ as your lord
and savior
yes you live no you die i mean that was
that was the spread of
of of christianity throughout the world
and this is going
to be essentially our new reality
for better for better or worse tracking
every single place that you go
and that gets added to some database
exactly you know to kind of quote the
social dilemma like we are the product
and
the data mining that can transpire when
there's an
app that basically logs every single
place that you go
well how long you're there when you when
you enter and when you depart
what is nutty is we're already dealing
with this in the you know okay we
you know okay google has a lot of data
facebook has a lot of data or credit
cards right
you go pull up the credit card statement
and you go okay brian went here
brian went there brian went to this
restaurant but
we in our minds don't go oh our
government knows that
mm-hmm but government knows that
whatever it is i stated
mata in or i stated a ritz-carlton right
we go okay our credit card company knows
that but our government doesn't know
that
well starting basically right now
our government and the international
governments around the world
are not only going to know everything
about us they're going to know
every place we walk into they're going
to know
whether or not i shop at gucci or
whether i shop at costco they're going
to know
if i ate dinner at nobu or if i went to
mcdonald's they're going to know
everything about us where we go
where we've been where we travel what
airline we board
because that is the only way when you
actually think about what's going to
happen with this covet vaccine
that it can actually be right
successful meaning okay you're going to
have
to show when you went to a place that
you've been vaccinated
and if you don't show you've been
vaccinated you're not going to be able
to go to the store
you're not going to be able to get on
the plane you're not going to be able to
go anywhere
there's got to be an analog solution to
that somehow
though i doubt it i mean i think the
analog solution is oh you don't have a
smartphone
so they're going to give you like a
driver's license that'll have like a
chip
or something but the driver's license is
going to be the same thing because
they're going to scan the driver's
license and it's going to go into the
same database
right so i i think you know this
this we've been dealing with this for
years
but you know i'm not a um
a conspiracy theorist and so i don't
view this as a conspiracy theory at all
and
i don't view this as a you know oh wow
but that big brother moment
is truly upon us i mean it is here
and it's not even the now i mean this is
the moment is upon us because when you
look at what's going to happen
over as the way that this vaccine rolls
out and you just use common sense you go
well
of course this is what's going to happen
you're not going to be able to enter a
restaurant unless you show you've been
that's going to have to establish it
and it and this is a national
international protocol meaning
okay you arrive in switzerland where's
trap orders boom
yeah you and this is going to be global
you go to a restaurant in zurich you're
going to scan the app you go to a
restaurant in italy you're going to go
anywhere in the world right
you're going to have to show that you've
been vaccinated and so now
brian and rich roll at every person on
the planet
unless you're living in a tribal village
in africa
right everything we do
everywhere we go everything we shop and
you think about this just in the case of
like
you know anything what this is
or you know the counter argument is
going to be similar to
the arguments that that you heard
uh with snowden in that oh it's just
metadata
we don't actually know anything about
you know what you did specifically we're
just getting
ones and zeros about whether people
entering and leaving
are healthy right i mean i'm sure
that'll be the response
of course unless they want to know
unless unless they go
um we're at the fbi like we need to
we pull up brian we think john smith
might be whatever right running a
fraudulent business yeah
and then boom at the end so instead of
instead of subpoenaing
uh the credit cards subpoenaing the
banks subpoenas
and you know doing that whole process
someone says right for office
right let's pull them off and you go oh
whoa this guy's uh
staying at this place he's on this
airline he's there
but he when he gets behind a microphone
he says this instead
yeah we can use that i think frightening
man
i think what is what is up what are we
gonna do
it's minority report it's it's all the
stuff that we've seen for years and
years
in in movies and science fiction
and blade runner and in 1984
which was you know uh
we latched on to 1984 as the theme of
icarus because not only was that
gregory's famous
favorite book but it's that whole idea
that
big brother's watching that you're never
going to beat
the system that ultimately the system
has the strength and the government is
is
is is who is in charge and
you know you see this in the dissident
or
not only in the murder of jamal but but
uh the aftermath of this that there's no
punishment
and that my film doesn't get distributed
by a major streamer and the government's
not right
it's all these themes this orwellian
theme of 1984
and now we're seeing it in our lives and
i think
and i think covet for better for worse
because we all want to get back to our
lives
is we're all going to line up and sign
up for it is that big brother moment
it is upon us it is that true true true
big brother moment
hmm it's a very dystopian note to end
this whole thing on
but one thing we could do is you know
all your movies always
have a call to action too like how can
somebody who's
um who sees the film or listens to this
and feels inspired to
get involved like where do you direct
that attention
well um we uh you know the human rights
foundation
um every everything
uh the film was basically made uh
through charitable donations
um a lot of the marketing and
advertising again is being supported
through charitable donations
um and uh that's all coming from the
human rights foundation
so you know i think there's a couple
ways to get
involved um one
doesn't involve you know any money it's
it's
it's purely what we saw with the arab
spring or what we see
in great movements or black lives matter
or me too
um or any one of these
movements um that take action
is they start at the you know at an
individual level and it grows and grows
and grows and voices are heard
and i think that in the case of this
there's a way to have your voice heard
which is
you know you you send a letter to your
congressman
to your senator you go on their their
websites and
you send an email and you say hey you
know i want you to take
take action against human rights abuses
in saudi arabia
there should be punishment for the
murder of jamal khashoggi
there should be accountability i
don't condone you emmanuel macron
or you justin trudeau or you name the
person right
doing business with this country so long
as they
are beheading 800-900 people a year for
doing nothing more than tweeting
um so long as women are sitting in jails
because they advocated for the right to
drive
uh or people are being imprisoned simply
for voicing an opinion
right so there's that and that is a call
to action
the other of course is looking at the
human rights foundation
and um either getting involved with them
in a volunteer level
or getting involved in a donation base
uh because the work that they're doing
through the awesome freedom forum and if
you
do a deep dive i mean it's you know
countries all over the world
that they are supporting dissidents they
are supporting
uh people who have um otherwise been
forced to leave their country
essentially for wanting free speech
or have you know or or or family members
of people who have been murdered in
these countries
uh for fighting for freedom of press or
freedom of speech or human rights
um so that's the other place to get
involved
and then you know um i think as
as biden takes office um i believe that
there's
a potential real kind of reimagining of
the u.s saudi relations
and there's the you know yet another way
to get involved in that
sort of advocacy um
and uh i mean i think i think those are
are the ways to uh to get involved to
make an impact and hopefully
uh most powerfully is to see the film
um and to tell your friends about this
film
because um that leads
to change what what happened with icarus
was
the film being on netflix and being seen
had a ten thousand times bigger impact
than the new york times than cnn then
all of the stories and everything before
because all of a sudden there was a
global audience that could see this film
and that pressure led the ioc the
olympic committee
to take action and that is still
survived to this day
and i believe that this film if seen by
enough people
can have the same effect uh on
foreign policies all over the world
regarding saudi arabia
and it's not so much about punishment
for
mbs it's not oh does muhammad bin salman
wind up in a jail that's unrealistic
but can this film lead to pressuring
change that tens of thousands of people
that are falsely jailed in saudi prisons
are released and allowed to have freedom
of speech
or allowed to voice their opinions on
twitter
without fear of retribution i believe
that that is possible
you know if enlightenment comes and
sometimes you know a leader can become
enlightened because he realizes
that um by by
oppressing opinions doesn't
doesn't really lead to any good that you
can actually be a kind
leader that you can be a good leader
that
uh even if you're a king it doesn't mean
that you need to be a bad king you can
be a good king
and that's kind of my hope with this
film and that was kind of khashoggi's
whole thing
early on right that was his whole thing
yeah
i mean he his last breath and everything
was you know like i mean hey
i'm not i'm not i'm not
calling for um you know the french
revolution here
he wasn't you know this this he was not
advocating you know to go round up the
royals and behead them yeah
he was advocating the smallest of
changes
that simply that the royal family
opened up the system to more of a
parliamentary system but he believed and
he said this over and over again
that one man's opinion the leadership
of one person and only one person
under any situation cannot be good
that the best leadership has to be yes
there's a leader
like a president but that there are
other voices that are heard
and what he saw and saw in the kingdom
is that there was no other voice
other than mbs and and what's outlined
in the film also
is the roundup of the ritz carlton where
he arrests all
the other princes and businesses leaders
and shakes them down for money
what he's done since taking powers of
crown prince is basically
you know lock up anybody who can oppose
him
that he goes hey this is this is not the
best way to lead
the best way to lead is is through
kindness through
allowing other opinions and listening to
other opinions
and ultimately not in service to to
you know the global the sort of
prosperity that he seeks
and the approval of the global community
upon which he's reliant upon if he wants
to actualize his
vision 2030. what's really strange is um
you know the trip that he took to the
united states
um which was just months before the
khashoggi
murder i think and and i can be
misquoted here i think it was like
march of 2018 um and khashoggi was
murdered in october 2018.
um i'm pretty i'm pretty sure it was
march thereabouts
he comes to the united states muhammad
bin salman
and he had hired all these companies
like mckinsey
and all these huge consulting firms that
he was paying
hundreds of millions of dollars to
basically promote
him in washington and among business
leaders
as the great reformers this young prince
this great you know
you know this guy is is is
loved and he is so cool and he's hip and
and even when he was in the united
states he was wearing a suit
right and he wasn't wearing a headdress
and he wasn't wearing
uh the traditional saudi garments right
so it's like okay this is a
enlightened islam this is an
enlightened leader he's western
right and that's how he presented
himself
and he took these meetings with
everybody from
obama to uh
to jeff bezos to bill gates to
you know on and on and on and on elon
musk you know
and they set up and he went to
washington and then he came to los
angeles and took over the entire four
seasons on tahini
shut the entire hotel down i mean like i
mean what an ego i mean like
really yeah you needed to take the
entire
hotel all whatever it is 300 rooms
like did he do the thing where they fly
in you know on their own jet and then
have all their cars
like in the car yeah i mean when you've
seen this guy out with the rolls royces
and everything
i mean he's literally flying on like his
own airbus right
and not only is he on like his own
airbus or whatever it is
he's then got like fighter jets
following right here you see that in the
movie
refueling him as he flies and then he
lands and there's
and you know whatever it is there's the
airbus and then he's like got a 747 i
mean it's it's
the most it is the most crazy
over-the-top insane you know
you think our president or whatever the
secret service or something travels you
know
air force one forget about it i mean
this is
this is a thousand times that i mean
you know this is insane but i remember
when he came to the us and it was
the you know it was this there was that
that sense
that you know this great reformer is
here and things are going to change
but where i was going with this is that
consultants and security experts that i
said is so apparently
wherever he went um so he locked himself
up in this four seasons in beverly hills
and then he did the same thing in
silicon valley
and he would not go
meet with anybody so all the meetings
were hosted
on his turf right and there were all
these like silver briefcades that were
being pulled in and
and one of the
[Music]
the guys in the film the head
you know cyber security guy who was
running uh
white house cyber security and fbi cyber
security
is that there is a lot of beliefs and
apparently you know
investigations that they believe
that they were essentially
using these meetings he was getting the
numbers phone numbers of people
like jeff bezos right and then
he could then deploy pegasus on
because because they they were hacking
bezos months before the khashoggi murder
so you wonder who else did he get wow
who else did he get so these these
meetings while they're for business
he was also using it uh to basically
hack uh the phones of leaders all over
the world
hey let's stay in touch on whatsapp all
right hey
whatever hey nice to meet you elon musk
what's your number hey what's your
number
right yeah
yeah you would think like after after
the bezos thing
all those guys are like you know looking
at their getting somebody on their phone
to make sure they're
locked down i don't i don't i certainly
don't know that for a fact but it would
be a uh it'd be a wise thing to do
i would say well if all you wanted to do
is make documentaries about
subjects like this you you would be able
to do that for the rest of your life i
think
you know even the idea of doing one
around the vaccine
or around you know
saudi investment in you know united
states entertainment companies like
there's no end to these threads that you
can pull
on the themes that you know obviously
speak to you
you know uh uh i i i think that what
will be interesting for me is this this
film has been
really two full years of my life
uh uh it was
um a year and a half
to make it uh i'm still working on this
every single day
you know two two years into it um and so
these stories
really take over my life i mean you know
because icarus was such a personal story
and uh uh i'm still very
you know involved actually just passed
in congress uh
and the senate the rada the rachenkov
act anti-doping act
just passed last week through the senate
it's waiting for trump's signature
which is going to be incredibly
gratifying which is amazing so ruchenkov
actually has
a law passed in him that the united
states has passed
to basically try to manage global
doping and sports because wada is so
ineffective
and basically criminalizing this in the
u.s courts and
there's all these logistics around it
but basically
it it makes it that if an athlete comes
the united states and if there's you
know there's
a chance of anti-doping act just just
passed uh
and uh and russia is still banned from
global
sport and so these it's it's lived on
and
so i think for me um it's really looking
at
stories that i think that i can tell
that can possibly have a
a global impact that can have a
resonance behind it and live on i'm
hoping that
the dissident and the story behind the
murder of jamal khashoggi
will be that and certainly in other
subject matter that that i'm looking at
and i think the
the hard thing and the question kind of
becomes
what is that future in having
uh material like this distributed
because it is becoming
more and more difficult and you know
just for example and we talked about
this but had the human rights foundation
not
come in and supported this film
it wouldn't have gotten made yeah um
i had went to all sorts of um people
before
you know thor and i meet up and they
were all scared to finance it
right and uh
so you know when you have this level of
fear going on that is
perpetuating societies the question is
is what is
that next story and
will that next story be able to be just
told honestly
and that kind of leads into the whole
whether
it's you know the false narratives going
out going on around you know election
fraud
uh or it's the false narratives that get
put
out of russia or saudi or anything else
i think it's becoming harder and harder
to just have something just go
the truth is the truth is the truth and
we used to
go you'd pick up the new york times and
go okay it's a new york times
it's the truth right and now you
even have 50 of the country going the
new york times is not the truth
the new york times is fake news
and you go okay how does this come to a
place
where this stops where the news becomes
the news again
truth becomes truth again facts become
facts again
and i don't have those answers i mean
finding our way back to that is is very
difficult
and the irony being of course that we've
never had greater
immediate access to more information and
yet
our level of trust in that information
has never been lower
meanwhile there's this squelching of
expression
that is making it more difficult for
films that
are endeavoring to tell the truth or
shed light
on a difficult truth like your own film
and how do we see our way forward from
that like it does feel like
somebody should put together a streaming
platform
that is just all about stories like this
that are
that are difficult and it's got to be
about the truth and the message and not
about
how it's going to fare in the global
marketplace or
you know how we're going to grow this
streaming enterprise
across the world and garner the
investment from
these problematic nation states
that needs to be done i mean you're um
there are philanthropists in the world
uh uh lauren powell jobs uh
right funded uh concordia davis
guggenheim's company
about a year ago uh i mean they
participants still exist don't they
are they yeah but they're not doing this
very they're basically no longer doing
political content
and and and the problem with participant
is that these models are financially
based so um
[Music]
participant is finding that you know
there's not whatever profit to be had
in these models so i've been told that
they're shying away from a lot of this
um so i think that you know what's gotta
happen is or
or the perfect world is you have a
philanthropist
you know uh whether it's someone like a
lauren jobs or it's a jack dorsey who
you know is who is you know uh
i i feel like how he's handled twitter
and you know has
been pretty cool and he's certainly
uh pretty enlightened he's a perfect
candidate
i think he would be super interested in
this idea all right
dorsey or maybe an elon musk or
you know even a bill gates uh
um that goes okay you know what what am
i gonna do with all this
wealth what are you gonna do with it you
can't
once you're worth more than whatever it
is a couple hundred million dollars what
are you gonna do with it
if you got 10 billion dollars you're
making a billion two billion dollars a
year just on the interest on your
billions i mean
you can't spend it i mean even like bill
gates where you say okay
his mandate is i'm giving away all my
wealth it doesn't matter how much he
gives away
every year his wealth increases and
increases you're going like
wait but i thought you were giving it
all away but at the same time
microsoft just keeps doubling and
doubling and doubling and doubling the
guy can't give away enough money fast
enough yeah i mean so
so ultimately i think you look at
one of these people or or
persons that go you know
just just as much as i want to give away
my wealth to help
um you know fight poverty in africa
or just as much as i want to give away
my my wealth
to fight you know research of vaccines
or um or irrigation systems or this
and the other well i want to give away
my wealth
to see to it um that there is a global
platform that is well
funded well financed
well endowed that you've got that app
just like netflix that you can go to and
that
there isn't so much of a financial model
behind it
as there is a philanthropic model behind
it
to see to it that stories like this get
told um
to me and to you know to have have
consumers subscribe to it for a couple
bucks
makes it you know economically viable
right exactly i mean if if it's
something where
you know the guy's got to decide okay do
i pay my 14.99 for netflix
or do i pay my 14.99 for whatever it is
truth
you know well that becomes difficult but
if it's a
but if it's a you know if it's a
subscription that is
whatever 299 and you know that you're
going to go on there
and you're going to have all sorts of
content
that otherwise big media companies that
are only looking at shareholder
accountability
growth in the region subscriber numbers
risk
assessment of all these other things
that make it impossible to do that kind
of content and if you have something
like that
um that could be very very powerful all
right
so all you billionaires out there
listening give brian a call
exactly right i uh
i've thought about this many times and i
do think that that is
i do think that this is uh or will be
the future
um of stories like the dissident
because i don't see these global media
companies changing i mean even if you
look at
a company like let's say hbo a few years
ago
well now it's you know warner media and
att i mean it's
it's all interconnected yeah it's a
giant conglomerate right so the
so as these conglomerates take hold and
you know the amazons of the world
um everything becomes a risk
a risk assessment yeah yeah it's
interesting because the streaming
the streaming universe has you do have
to credit it
with providing the opportunity for
a lot of independent stories to be told
and shared and celebrated in a way that
would not have been possible in the
theatrical window model so it has done
you know like not as many people would
have seen icarus
if it were not for netflix of course so
it's like you know it's like it's
unbelievable
the power of these platforms to help
you know smaller filmmakers and stories
that aren't going to get green lit
you know to be in the multiplex and yet
at the same time
there is this risk analysis that is
having this
squelching impact well what you have is
like in the case of netflix the the
netflix that did icarus
three years ago is not the netflix of
today
it's a different company you know that
was a company that had 100 million
subscribers versus 200 million
subscribers
that was a company that was um
very hungry at the at the time to uh
show that it could be an awards
contender show that it could
you know uh uh
evolve beyond um you know house of cards
and
uh and it was it was a different company
um three years ago uh and
and what happens for better for worse
because look
i i love netflix i mean the majority of
i mean
queen's gambit that i just finished
watching is
extraordinary it's extraordinary and
there's so much extraordinary content on
there
and i am sure that i will continue to
to do content make content
and have content on netflix they're
awesome
and they're amazing what they do i love
them but
on the other hand because of how big
they are and the growth that they've had
and
where they're at in the world right now
there is a whole other risk model that
comes into it
and in many ways you can't you can't
fault him
either because if you're running that
company
the burden that comes
on top of that to grow
uh to have shareholder value and to also
not put your company at risk
also becomes very very hard and i don't
so i don't have that answer to it
because at the same time i don't
i i'm not i'm not angry at them
i love them i think they're amazing and
i love
what they're doing and i love the
content and and and
the form that they've provided for so
many people and what they did for icarus
was
outstanding and astounding um
at the same time there's a conundrum
where something gets so
big that risk assessment
will always get in the way or become
you know a variable as to whether you do
something or not yeah
we gotta end this thing um
everybody please go see this movie
it was uh very impactful for me i've
seen it twice
i was moved by it made me think
uh it's a heavy film but it also like we
said at the outset
you know definitely a thriller you're on
this roller coaster ride as this story
unfolds and
you did this with a master stroke like
it's it's extraordinary so
congratulations on the movie it opens
december 25th
in limited theaters and then january 8th
on your vod
platform yes it'll be available on
demand
uh to rent uh on basically all platforms
beginning
january 8th yeah check it out and in
theaters december 25th
if you have a theater open near you
right
um you can learn more about it at
thedissident.com
and you can find brian pretty easily on
the internet at brian fogle right
yeah uh at brian fogle on
twitter or instagram i keep private but
yeah
i if you add me all right make sure
you're not a saudi troll
and uh you might not know
you know what i mean you should know
better than anyone
it's funny yeah i mean i keep my
accounts private because uh
i very rarely i don't have a lot of time
for it but then i'll click
and and i go wait you're this looks like
a honey pot or something you know i
click and it's like something you must
be
everything that comes in you must think
do i really want to click on like
i'm like um this doesn't look like a
real person
right you know or you know or something
clicks in and i'm like
uh yeah there's something right here
what are we going to do go ride our
bikes yeah let's go ride bikes how about
that
go ski go ride bikes cool because that's
what we will do for sure
uh thank you man that was super powerful
um so much respect for
putting yourself out there in a really
powerful way to forge positive change
it's
it's uh it's an example for me and
and how i think about how i interface
with the world and i know for so many
people out there so
i appreciate you my friend thanks rich
it's good to be
back on and talking to you again cool
you're amazing
and uh any of you haven't seen rich's
new book
you have to get it it's incredible it's
on my coffee table yeah
because you're in it i
thank you peace peace
[Music]
you